If it's possible, can you just
recap season one in 30 seconds?
Thirty seconds?
It's really difficult
to do that in 30 seconds.
-Forty seconds.
-Forty, okay.
Okay.
Can I do it with words, like…
There is a problem.
Sun.
Basically playing hide-and-seek
with the sun in a plane.
A plane.
We are just escaping the disaster
and trying to survive.
Death.
So they have to build
their safety together.
And survivors.
Very good.
I've been waiting
in Bulgaria in a bunker
for the crew
from the plane to come,
and just… "I just waited there
to save you guys."
"I'm here all for you."
What happens in season two
in 30 seconds?
It's the same people.
I can't say it.
We are in a bunker, big spoiler,
and they are in more big shits.
The Flight 21 folks,
which we know from season one,
arrive at the bunker,
and at the bunker,
they're gonna meet a new group
where they meet Markus, of course.
And it's just like
mashed together.
Passengers start to do
whatever they want.
We have to sort of,
yeah, restore order.
And they're trying also
to sort things with the sun.
How will the sun problem
be solved?
In Horst we trust.
It's a good question. I don't know.
We are in the bunker.
We try to survive. There is food,
then there goes
something wrong with food.
The group splits. Yeah.
I'm spoiling it.
So the group splits.
Half of the group are going
to Norway to find the seeds.
So that makes it that only
the other half is still in the bunker.
The second season now,
it's more in survival mode.
It's even more about loyalty
and betrayal, friendship.
Yeah, there's, like, a family,
and when we are family,
more shit happens, so,
yeah, that's gonna happen
for season two,
and we're gonna rock it.
Okay.